we are recording and never speaking of
what we were speaking of before no stop
report
once they find the bodies
um
can i say something
so
this week marked
a
uh
seminal
watershed moment in my son's life
he
after much many many attempts by both
pam and i our lovely nanny was able to
finally
get him to go to build a bear
um
so he goes to build a bear
fascinated by what was the how did the
resistance to that play out does he get
this i was like dude do you want to go
no i walked in with him once he was like
not into it i'm like oh okay okay cool
is this like a pivotal thing of an
american childhood no
no it's just for the record i've never
been in one of those places i hadn't
either and by the way you should never
go in one without a child
it's just weird they're like can we help
you sir can we help you
two places
are a build-a-bear and a victoria's
secret
because they're just like why are you
really here like no i promise i'm not
buying a man walks away
i would i would if i am ever in one of
those kinds of stores and i see a man in
there and i clearly looking around
confused i'm like bless his heart it's
will smith's enemy of the state by the
way she doesn't care she doesn't want
anything with his electronic uh device
said that you can see she or he does not
want they buy
so that's that's the setup so he uh he
builds charlie
charlie is a bear
um and you can choose a sound i wish i
had charlie buck not in here right now
um
when you squeeze charlie's hand charlie
makes uh any sound you want you can like
choose from like a bunch of different
ones my son chooses
the imperial march from star wars
oh no
which was both what does that mean
instantly comforting and also
off-putting
so
i was like dude do you want to watch
star wars and he was like yeah check it
i i want to see what this is all about
oh he hadn't seen star wars when he
picked imperial match he's just like
that's a cool tune he was like that's
awesome and i was like okay and so this
is like
told me about the history of the
conversation this music it was amazing i
was like uncle austin needs to come over
for dinner right now
um and explain to you so many things
that you're missing um
about both the music and the world but
he watching i got to finally see like
this four-year-old brain try to process
who everybody is and what's happening
what's going on who he loves he
loves the stormtroopers i'm terrified of
my child he's like stormtrooper
gets really excited let's go
yeah i just realized that the second
moment you were talking about was seeing
stalls not build them not building a
bear yeah okay not building a bear but
just caught up me too me too yeah but
the cool thing is when chewbacca came on
of course i had to you know i broke into
my
bad wookie
and then traveler looked at me and like
looked at
chewie and he was like i want to do that
and so
him running around our house going
trying to make the chewbacca sound oh
coolest sound in the entire world it's
just awesome so
multi-generational voice acting dynasty
[Music]
that's pretty awesome the giant walking
carpet
did he and harrison's forward body
language when he was just like we're all
fine we're all fine here how are you
he's like on like a
i like that you called him harrison's
ford
harrison's ford
that's much my favorite mission
does a four-year-old
how much of
character and plot do they understand or
is a lot of it just sort of visual and
sound
traveler's always been very like like
back to the future and this is how it
was always introduced there was some
kind of like um totem or or you know
piece of paraphernalia from something he
was like what's that about and
he he loves cars cars vehicles he's very
mechanically engineering mind um and so
he was like i was like do we need to go
to best buy he goes can i get a car i'm
like tell you what man you can find a
car at best buy
i'll buy it for you
he found found some 500 remote control
yeah i was like [ __ ] yeah uh he found a
uh
uh like a scale model of the delorean
and i'm like well i'm absolutely gonna
buy that for you and he just fasted
anybody was a one-to-one scale model
it was in the parking lot
which by the way if anyone wants to buy
you've got some merchandise you got to
unload
he uh he was it was like so it's like
this is awesome and bush and i'm trying
to like tell that's a flux capacitor
he's looking at me like you're drunk dad
i'm like maybe a little but i was like
do you want to see this and so we like
watched the opening of just when the
delorean comes out of of the back of the
car and stuff and he's like holy crap
and so we got to watch all parts of his
there's three main moments in that movie
where he wants to watch since the first
time it goes 88 and hearing my son he
every every bad guy is now a libyan
um so oh no the libyans are here it was
like
so confusing um it's like that's that's
only a word that we say at our house he
can't run around going look dad olivia
no no no no no
um but it's just it's it's so it's so
fun to like
to to experience this stuff through
like fresh eyes it makes me um i mean
i'm a big nerd anyway obviously but
i forget the first time to see something
and i i i'm always um excited when
that's why i think i lied a lot when i
was growing up about seeing stuff or
saying that i'd read a book or played a
game or saw a movie just because i was
afraid of feeling left out and now i
actually embrace it because i love
seeing people light up and they're like
can we go stop our entire lives and go
play this or
watch this or did i did i um
did i go on about my music history
professor here before who would ask the
class
we don't know probably but go ahead
during the whole episode
a lot of just got bored of before that
guys no no i
i don't feel like i told it here but i
love telling the story so it's
inevitable that i
thought i had but anyway my music
history professor at nyu
is maybe the greatest teacher i've ever
had i mean he's truly amazing and he
could hold
court with 300 kids in a lecture hall
300 like 18 year old bored
you know no no amount of
being you know at college to study your
chosen subject is enough to overcome it
was it by rapping like they'd all do do
in the movies i didn't interrupt i just
want to point the fact
i technically stopped in court i just
asked a question no because i said you
stopped too and people were saying you
still interrupted him i was like he
finished this door he cut him off as
long as i don't say fast bender's
british again i think that's better
yeah no it's fair enough it's fast did
he rap like they do in the movies
no i think that would have been the
the most unhim thing i could possibly
imagine not a rapper yeah no he was he
was he was very professorial uh in the
cliche sense of what that means but he
was such an unbelievable lecturer so
captivating and
he he had taught at nyu since 1968 he
wrote the textbooks himself so he gave
you his textbook and he knew everything
cold like i mean it was just this was
this was a guy that
clearly had this material down but it
didn't feel like
a um
you know
going by through the motions sort of
like okay today we're going to talk
about mozart it was so you basically
today
honestly this guy shaped this guy shaped
who i am i started to spend time with
him like we became close friends he
sadly got cancer very shortly after i
graduated and i i literally i flew to
his funeral like we became pretty close
i was gonna make a joke about how you
murdered him and put his skin on and now
this is all covered sorry about that
i like that you felt too sad to say the
joke but not sad enough to tell us
that's what you were doing
you could have saved yourself trying to
be honest
so he um
he uh
i remember
this is a lecture hall every music major
is acquired sorry sorry i'll say troy's
being attacked by the invisible ninja we
have to address [ __ ] mosquitoes man
this year are just oh i looked down and
i missed it it's all really bad right
they are and
like the conspiracy theorist in mind is
like los angeles released 35 million
mosquitoes i'm like and they're [ __ ]
they're i tell you what if my guy had a
one
we wouldn't have these skaters out here
ain't no skaters would we skater no we
wouldn't have no skaters we would never
skates at all
sorry austin go ahead you need to have
the voice you were talking about your
professor
anyway the point was
uh they're gonna animate that i can't
wait
now they gotta animate this part this is
the good part uh
um
he uh
this thing about vicariously
experiencing something new for the first
time that's what all this was
leaping off of because he goes um
you know we would get to the major like
we're working our way it was a four
semester class two years
working your way from the medieval
period all the way to modern times
through essentially like the european
classical music history
um and so really detailed but every now
and again you cover you come to like a
beethoven and he's gonna talk about you
know a fifth symphony or a ninth
symphony so
a lot of it is music that
a student is not likely to have heard
before but as someone who had to
audition to get into music school the
big ones theoretically there's no way
you've gotten this far and haven't heard
you know the ride of spring beethoven's
fifth mozart's you know requiem whatever
like the the the truly
staples but he would always
before each one of those go who here has
never
heard this piece like a beethoven's fit
and out of 300 or 400 kids in a lecture
hall there'd be like five that would
very shyly go like
i've never heard beethoven's fifth i
don't know how and remember he'd single
out those students and go i so envy that
you're about to experience this for the
first time this is one of the greatest
works of art in the whole of human
history and all the rest of us it's old
news you're you're literally about to
taste something for the first time that
has stood the test to me that that was
one of those watershed moments of
realizing how amazing
how precious it is to have not
experienced something
that you know
two kids who have a youtube channel
where they just react to songs i'm sure
we spoke about that yeah yeah it's
incredible one of them was enter the
scene
wasn't inner sandman was one of them or
it was like in the air tonight i
remember like phil collins i was going
to say i remember phil collins once
watching them listen to like
what would be classic rap or hip-hop and
being shocked if they haven't heard it
is very very cool like it's like what's
it called i feel like i've seen so many
reaction
youtube channels that i don't know if
i've seen this one it's kind of a
different definition of ignorance is
bliss right like the being ignorant is
itself uh yeah a source of joy you know
at the moment of becoming i guess less
ignorant by experiencing something
it's funny when you talking about
watching star wars with traveler i
remember
i remember i was probably six when i saw
it i was a little older than he was and
i remember it was one of those was a
similar premise though where my dad
was like
you know
it's time
um actually because i had developed an
obsession with indiana jones and my dad
goes you know he was in another movie
that i think you'd like american
graffiti now i wasn't able to find what
the channel name is but uh the
conversation try jim
find it james oh
i had a uh
very good experience like that of um a
friend of mine played the last of us
maybe like years
after it came out and she was playing it
over a very long period of time you're
like you've gotta try mass effect he's
great at that
um she's playing it over a long period
of time because she has really bad
motion sickness with video games so it
takes a while to get through things
and
as soon as i because i was downstairs we
lived together um as soon as i
realized that she was at the end of the
game because i could hear it i just came
up the back of the staircase and just
watched and just like listened to her as
she was watching the end of the game all
through the credits i think she cried
getting to watch somebody go through
that and like see them process it in
real time because i've never done that
before i processed it but i'd never
watched someone else process it and have
no concept of what was happening was
very very cool to watch and be like so
what did you think how do you feel about
this were you feeling as always how are
you watching watching um
the brian and amelia uh
play last of us too
um
on their stream and get so
like at the kind of true gut punch
moments towards the end
like just see them sort of melt down and
like literally go
we may need to kind of pause the stream
like we're
we're really
kind of
uh yeah like it was one of those where i
found myself getting pulled in
like it was just one of those i think
angela messaged me like oh they're near
the end of the
the game and i so i turned i wasn't
watching the stream i turned it on kind
of right at the moment they started to
have their
their uh
sort of emotional meltdown and i was but
it was like a quiet it was like a
collapse it was just like they got
really quiet yeah and like couldn't talk
and i felt it it pulled me it pulled me
in and i felt like i was experiencing
the game for the first time and it's
like that's a rare
joy of it's of of a sort to to kind of
see things through someone's eyes i had
not watched a lot of movies um obviously
and
my uh one of my exes was very into film
but never wanted to show me movies like
there was this sort of rhetoric that you
found one film node that didn't want to
make yeah i was going to say
i guess they've really earned that title
of x
that he
had this thing that was kind of like
uh girls don't like that though like
said that about big lebowski which i did
since watched and really liked
uh yes
yeah you're the girliest girly girl i've
ever met
earlier than alana
uh but it's true troy's been late to
hanging out with me for the sake of
manicures far more times than any other
person i respect a manicure you gotta
get it's it's the there's the paraffin
you gotta do the pair sometimes though i
feel like with men they over shine the
nail
you look like you're [ __ ] sparkling
short and shiny i don't want to i don't
want them glittery i just want them
short and shiny that's all i want short
and shiny okay but um taking notes if by
the way if you've never
it's
done
it
for your health first of all
uh but if you've never done a a manicure
in a pedicure
go yeah totally good guys do it all the
time too i had guys in my high school
who were going to get them together
which i thought was the cutest thing
because they do like a boys only manny
petty day thing like a rose manicure
yeah yeah girls one allowed it's like
that's actually sick like i love that
what do you guys talk about like that's
awesome that's really funny i can't i
never knew anything take care of your
peds
that somehow feels related to this
apparent thing that was happening
recently that i didn't know but found
incredibly endearing of a bunch of like
high school boys all over the u.s going
to see the minions movie inside oh yeah
in suits yeah yeah and getting banned
for it i was like really what does that
ever ha they were not allowing them to
be in the theater they were like banning
people from wearing suits to the minion
thing i have no idea why
is that a thing
google it oh my god because i guess they
felt like they were being mocked but
like what an inoffensive mockery wow and
also a profitable one if they're playing
yeah yeah they wouldn't have gotten
another
one
my game then insult me is very welcome
like they were being they were being
turned away if they were wearing uh
suits wow there was another thing that
that was kind of like a
phenomenon that i really liked that men
were doing because i found it so cool
was sea shanties made a comeback on
tick-tock
and it's just a lot of men like adding
their voices to a sea shanty and i was
like we never celebrate men
collaborating artistically in this way
like i was like that's so [ __ ] cool
there are these teen boys just singing
with each other who may have never done
that before putting it on the internet
just like doing it and i was like
there's [ __ ] rules it's so cool to
watch like i made beautiful music but
anyway sorry the end of my story was
when i met rahul he made a list of all
the movies that i hadn't seen which is
like why i ended up watching the
godfather and all this other stuff that
american psycho that i've come to you
all about that he was like these movies
and the list is still not done we're
getting through it but it's been awesome
because you know he's obviously a very
big film fan it's the industry that he
works in and i finish watching something
and he's just like tell me everything
that you thought about it and then he
has a different perspective on it after
watching it with me as well because
maybe he hadn't for a while
it's it's very funny it's always
interesting
absolutely it does whatever
there are people in
there i have cleaners here because my
dad's coming tomorrow and so he's like
there are people outside of this room
i i'm i'm curious oh my god i want to
see what's on that list first of all and
where time cop falls first of all like
is it
at the very top and you're building up
[Applause]
there's one thing that we all understand
movie makers take the sciences
definitely gonna be upset about one of
these more than the others so i mean i'm
actually gonna go from five to one just
because i feel like one is very
offensive
um
memento weekend at bernie's yeah the
usual celebrities solids yes usual
suspects is solid bronson because i love
tom honey oh bronson's great shawshank
redemption
yeah can i put a pin in that because i
wanted to bring back shawshank keep
going the last the last of
i'll just down there no time cop on the
list there's probably a second message
i mean i can
just
tonight when
i said just be like we've got to watch
time caller the guys say it's amazing
we've gotta watch it
hey you're on play watch listen
you're on play watch listen hi who is
this
um
why haven't you not made me watch time
cop
yeah that time he can't hear you guys i
need to mention that because you're in
my headphones yeah there that i was
telling them about the list of movies
that we've been going through and
they've asked where is time cop on the
list like why haven't i mike and i are
confused in this time cop
is it because he respects me
because that's a girl the truth of the
matter is
yeah great whatever but yeah
there are more pressing issues i think
you need to work your way through
stallone i think out off the tear of
that from that being from that's fair
that is
more assessment
understood
i don't have i don't prioritize he just
says that because he wants to listen to
the music from rocky rockies
we watched cliffhanger
we did watch cliffhanger okay they said
that's fair they said that's fair yeah
that moment that moment right there was
very good
yeah i have been through a lot of clint
eastwood recently um thank you for your
time appreciate it they told me to bring
you in right now so
thank you very much you know what i i i
was i was gonna give him [ __ ]
but he's like he's he's
through he's through he's coming in the
right way you have i mean i would even
say god i almost i feel the bile rising
up on my throat when i say this but you
actually have to go through the path of
seagal in order to
fully appreciate one could even say
you might even split the path
yeah you kind of might even have to just
dabble for a second speakman
but anyway what shawshank redemption
um joshua production i think is my dad's
favorite movie um
i love it that way for me austin is
paused in a very like he just burped or
very
concerned it's just his face he has
resting face
resting burp face
butter stop making that face
sorry here
um
shawshank it was pointed out to me we we
watched this um uh
on on my channel a while back like two
years ago whatever and somebody pointed
out to me that it's the only
movie
for two men to love each other in a
heterosexual way
that's not broly
like this like a yeah like a lasting
compassionate life yeah
a completely
um i feel like it probably happens in a
lot of military movies but isn't that
sort of inherently bro
that's kind of broly i'm not i'm not
dogging on i'm not saying but like it's
not always like they live or whatever
but there's definitely most movies are
some level of action if there's if
there's any kind of like fraternal love
between two men and shawshank is the
only one that i can think of where that
exists i like i had never thought of it
on that level but red and andy
love each other that's what compels them
to get through everything there's a
little bit of that maybe a million
dollar baby
it just ends poorly
i do feel like that's two men who almost
are like co-inhabitants
and a million dollar baby still can't
believe it wasn't about
an actual baby
never why did she oh it's so sad that's
a really that's a really good i'm trying
to think of another right um
i wish i could give credit to who
pointed that out she's i believe she's a
film director as well please forgive me
that i'm not remembering your name at
the moment
um it's the social network's the same
but it's a break up so that doesn't
count yeah yeah i always remember
one of my favorite moments in return of
the jedi was
seeing
han and lando reunite after the battle
like at the very very very end of the
movie and there was such a genuine like
they didn't there because remember when
they part ways where han is talking
about the falcon and he's like you know
you're gonna bring it back in one piece
right like and he's like they're having
a hard time saying goodbye to each other
and he's also wearing his clothes
uh
lando is lando is wearing
han's clothes
in that no he's not the next scene he's
wearing when he's thinking you're
thinking at the end of empire that's
what i'm talking about what are you
talking about then you're changing the
subject off my [ __ ] story what are
you talking about uh i said the end in
return of the jedi oh sorry the last
time they see each other before the
battle sorry when he's entrusting the
falcon over to lando and he's going to
take the
you know the shoal the stolen uh sholin
i know i sounded like a lana the stolen
what the [ __ ] i'm just sitting here
oh weird
yeah i'm just i'm just trying to pay
homage to your okay yeah it was uh
respectful i basically what i'm saying
is that you talk like sean connery
but a woman a good slap
so yeah that uh that's the thing
i always remember loving that though
that that like because it was real
genuine
they they were actually genuinely
thrilled that the other made it through
and was okay you know what i mean and it
was it was like this beautiful the
difference is it's not a whole movie of
like their dynamic obviously so it's not
it's not the same as shawshank in that
to be honest a lot of it's like men in
competition or sure the only
relationships that are particularly
loving are uh top gun
could
could go like quintessentially bro
i feel it's a little bro but i mean
especially top gun
the the latest one
maverick like really really explored
like that's the foundation of it is the
love that he had from maverick yeah
i loved that movie
oh my god i really really enjoyed it
so it's travis willingham's favorite
movie like it's it's it's his
there's there's so much tied to it
and of course day one he was there and i
still hadn't seen it and i think it was
this was the last week that i was in
theaters
and
of course that probably extended because
it just keeps they did yeah millions get
it's still on the highest grossing of
the year still
yeah uh second high uh no it's the
highest grossing of the year for sure
but i think at least it was the biggest
river
but i we do this thing where uh for
certain movies like
laura and pam sit next to each other and
travis and i said next to each other
because they're just like you guys go be
goofy
over here this is a serious boy's corner
here yeah and so we're sitting there and
from the i'm not gonna say anything but
from the first frame i was like i got
chills like oh like it instantly gut
punches you in the best most beautiful
way and from the first frame first sound
you know what you're what you're in for
and i told you guys about top gun at all
when i saw it just to just to insert
this yeah i was like i think you're
underselling just how successful this
movie is it's the seventh highest
domestic
gross of all time holy [ __ ]
yeah
it's made or beat avatar or time yeah
it's zeroing in on 700 whoa
domestic u.s
damn i mean it had to have been super
expensive to make
it it was on it was on ice also for a
long time i know that i know that um
they did the score
like years ago like it was one of those
movies that was more or less finished
for a long time i think like just
literally on the shelf like during the i
think it was shocking
because joseph krasinski is that his
last name the director the the guy that
did like he did the tron movie he did
the the um
oblivion
um
he had that movie and a netflix movie
called spider head come out right on top
of each other because clearly after
finishing top gun he went and made a
whole other movie
and they came out literally
simultaneously as a result i really feel
and i don't care for him this isn't yeah
this isn't a disparage but at all it's
it's something that um i feel
film
doesn't often have the benefit of like
making games what they do which is an is
an incredibly long development cycle an
incredibly long
iterative uh testing cycle like
typically you make your movie you put
out in front of a test audience and you
come back you're like we can reshoot one
thing or we add which is what they did
with the first one fire the composer
that's what that's what's so wild about
the batgirl thing right is it it feels
like a video game cancellation like and
films don't do that that's actually what
i wanted to talk to you guys about today
was i was gonna open with
how did what does everyone think of
batgirl like that situation is not
something that i've ever heard of before
and i was like have any any of you had
any like near complete
projects cancelled like that
yes i had a game that we were doing adr
for and they literally burned the disks
like we were done we shot everything wow
japan
they were like it's not gonna be
profitable it would cost them more in
their mind throwing good money after bad
and i had an interesting conversation
with somebody about this is like why
would you do if it's already made why
wouldn't you just put it out and i think
let me just insert myself from my
opinion into this go ahead um i think
that it is brand for the show though i
feel like yes um
yeah it's what we're known for yeah this
is journalism we're doing
please stop saying your opinions
i i think that
it is a wonderful um demonstration of
where the industry has shifted to
because it's no longer in the light of
of top gun you know like look at these
incredible uh ticket sales i think it
could go down as one of the last big
huge blockbuster for the cinema and for
box office sales
and here's the shift that's happening to
hbo
what is the draw to be on their platform
everybody wants things to be on their
platform and if they spend 80 million
dollars
on something and it doesn't keep people
on their platform
the promotion of it
is a waste of money it can also
potentially adjust the quality of the
service overall absolutely like oh you
have that shitty thing on there we it it
it can spoil a teaspoon of oil in the uh
water supply of the substrate this is
netflix's problem like they've got
unbelievable piles of content and
and
that wasn't the situation with that girl
right that girl was a tax write-off so
right which i don't understand
that's not why they i i mean my
understanding is not like not like i was
in the they were able to take it as a
loss uh but i don't think that was the
motivation because obviously that's like
they had what they were planning on
that's what they said
but i think that it was also said that
it
performed poorly in uh no it did i i
looked into it it was interesting it got
the same kind of i think i think it's uh
been compared to it got the same as it
you know the the movie like
in terms of in terms of the audience
reaction yeah it was it was a relatively
well received in test screenings not
like you know
why does that happen if you read into it
mike what like i've never heard of you
knock a couple hundred million off your
tax bill
and if you're coming in and you're
taking over a company i guess the idea
is they're not going to make a couple of
hundred million
they're not well they wouldn't make it
directly also like and this is this is
the thing that often happens when
companies are uh change leadership like
you can't take credit for the stuff that
happened before you joined this happens
in games all the time by the way like
the worst thing that the worst news
developer can get is that their
publisher has got a new ceo
because suddenly anything that anything
that was in business and your business
was already going going that ceo can't
take credit for so many room watch how
clean and clean you can sweep right
clean and sweat and the number of times
that's killed you know projects i've
been lucky it's never happened to me but
like it happens all the time and then
you clean house you you get rid of a
bunch of stuff you you on paper show
some savings or some some tax write-offs
then you start your projects going
and when one of those is a hit you can
take credit for it yeah which is
disgusting
my
i don't think i'm even allowed to talk
about it i worked at a company where
that kind of thing happened where um uh
the directive was to work on one thing
and then a new leader came in and was
like nope all of you are doing the wrong
thing cut all of it get rid of some of
the people who are working on it pivot
to this but
the ceo really only did that
to have control not because it was a
good business strategy and it didn't pay
off like it was just like burn a bunch
of [ __ ] be like my company now i'm gonna
do it how i say to do it and it was just
it like it was it was a gross tactic it
wasn't the generous rate is that you
know
often they come in and they've got like
they do have a vision for how they want
the company to change and then if things
don't fit that vision that's that's the
generous read of it like that's not just
about ego but i think often it's about
ego as well right like so
it's always i've been caught up in it in
a very early stage in a project we had
something that was kind of rolling
through but it was very early so it
didn't cause us too much harm but yeah
it's a nightmare if i um
i re i know it's the public statement is
obviously always going to have a certain
amount of spin
uh but the statement that the guy up for
getting his name the like zazlov or
whatever the the the new the new
the new guy in charge at warner the guy
from discovery you know yeah
the comment that i heard that actually
rang as very pl very understandable to
me was
that movie had originally been budgeted
you know on the the mid to high
you know like tens of millions like 70
million something like that
and then they had injected a bunch of
additional money bringing it closer to
100 in the hopes of
really kind of
amping it up as a spectacle because they
they were realizing
it's not gonna the way he phrased it in
the press release or whatever was
that the modern audience member for like
a superhero movie expects a certain
amount of
just craziness like visual and set piece
and stunts and a lot a lot of and that
the film had basically been kind of
initially built to
differently they said it was initially
built for streaming services well that's
the other aspect i wonder if it's a
factor and i and to be clear like
obviously none of us know any of this
but like
one of the theories i thought was
interesting was um
uh during the pandemic um hbo did that
thing where they simultaneously released
in the states right whereas the movement
come out in the cinema exactly it's day
and day come out on the streaming and i
i believe this new guys basically said
like
that's devaluing our movies things have
to go to the cinema first
um and then he's kind of put his
flagging around there and and that would
kind of support what austin's saying
that if this was something that was
going to be a cinema and yeah limited
release of the cinema and streaming but
with an intention that streaming would
be its main draw if this now kind of
falls between those two posts and they
don't think they would do well with an
initial cinema release that could also
be the exhibition but as i said the
testing went pretty well for it so that
doesn't necessarily must have been a
nonsense i got a quote here from an
expert james l bando blue junior
a partner new york law sperm who was
talking about an expert yes everyone
loves james m vanderbilt basically the
stephen hawking following following his
career for decades
very passionately by shelving the
batgirl film warner bros will be able to
reduce the loss incurred in producing
batgirl against its net income from the
other movies thus the loss of batgirl
will be reduced taxable income warner
bros did incur costs and thereby lose
money by producing the film and
receiving no income in return as such it
is not as though there is a tax benefit
being obtained here with it without a
non-tax cost
so
it's not like they're making money from
it it just disappears but also when you
fit when the so this is again like an
oversimplification but with a movie
release when you see the budget we
talked about this actually i think last
week when we were talking about predator
like sorry about prey the um
when you release a movie the budget of
the movie in terms of its production you
basically double at launch rate because
you put that money again into marketing
yeah so it's also that right it's also
saving that enormous amount of marketing
which which we've coincided so
if there's nothing else you've
i saw a lot of people on twitter sort of
being like just release it already and
i'm like you know the the amount of
effort that it takes to get it over that
last yeah you know last one also you
can't make the time if you do release it
except though
yeah doing this is like the best
marketing strategy that batgirl ever had
like i had forgotten that movie was
being made and now we're all like what
is it enough but now they can't even
if that's part of the strategy of like
we don't think that this thing will will
stand up on its own we have to create
some controversy over it in order to
stir up
interest but if you take away from con
now because of the taxes that would be
oh they can't ever release it it can't
be released they can't you can't yeah
once you they would otherwise owe that
money back
yeah interesting um a warner bros
spokesperson said the decision to not
release back goals is just their pr
point i
dave i believe yeah classic dave from uh
warner bros reflects our sorry that the
decision to not release backer reflects
our leadership strategic shift as it
relates to the dc universe and hbo max
so it's something to do with
do you think there's a distance in the
room
i don't know like i you know up until
dc's have their own streaming [ __ ] was
crazy it was technically warner but like
rooster teeth is uh owned by
one of them definitely like i would be
terrified if i was still working there
now it was like they just have a huge
mega corporation and then all the
smaller companies and like watching that
stuff happen to be like oh actually they
got rid of this partner that we had and
this one's now under this one like
watching that happen was nuts
and scary your question if you've ever
seen that on a game yeah um i've i've
definitely had games personally that
were canceled but usually not that far
to the end however a friend of mine
i don't know how much of this is public
so i'll be very vague i feel like it's
all the details of this are are public
but
i had a friend
uh who worked on a game that was
massively high profile and massively
high budget
and they they literally flew to london
recorded the entire score with the
london symphony huge mega orchestral
undertaking and the thing was literally
100 finished it wasn't most of the way
finished it was basically shippable
and
new ownership came in and to the point
that mike was saying
of like it was basically
we don't we didn't make this this was my
interpretation of why they would do this
they basically go we didn't make this
thing
so it's done it's gone and like and it
makes you realize
in a multi-billion dollar acquisition
um
you know
even a 50 million or 80 million dollar
thing kind of disappearing in the cracks
is just like part of the expense yeah
people may be worked on that for years
but that amount of money in this kind of
acquisition is just nothing that's wild
i had assumed that it wouldn't have
happened in games where you both have
stories of it happening i know things
get games get cancelled all the time
when a publisher is not into it they
lose funding whatever that's not
uncommon but things being like
in post in that kind of way yeah there
have been there have been this not only
happens like in film or games but i mean
i've i've no stories of people that were
on tour like they were a band and same
thing there's the label changes hands
and all of a sudden it's like they go
line item they go
cut cut cut cut cut cause i didn't sign
these bands i didn't sign these bands i
didn't sign these bands and they've
literally been on the road they're like
we just got dropped by our label
so
and that's that's potentially
i mean tens of thousands of dollars and
all of their recoupable money that they
have to contractually make back
to the to the label that put them out on
the road and they're there they have
that tab on them that they can't
continue to support and pay that back
so it's like this happens all the time
and it's it's
i was that i was so unfamiliar with and
i guess i assumed a lot about this word
too because of the scale of the
background news but maybe it's just that
it's not been like an ip that's this
recognition it's funny did you see the
other film as much i think that's a big
thing
with big budget films in particular it
doesn't happen as much yeah it happens
all the time in development movies all
the time will attach a star
they'll be ready to shoot then some
other offer comes along the star goes
i'm going to do this and the whole thing
falls apart i don't think that metal
gear movie's ever coming out
there have been a yeah there's been a
million i've had so many directors that
i've worked with over the years who
called me and be like we're doing this
thing and then a month later all the rug
got pulled out by one factor or another
and
but the um
the uh um
uh
[ __ ] that made me lose my train of
thought uh
that you were saying
talking about about it being failing to
it's less common in film is the last
thing mike said
we broke austin all right
i've been checking in with all my
friends who have like things in
development over warner brothers just
like how you doing they're like trail
went cold or we're fine
but there's there's uh
oh i know what it was go i'm cutting you
off did you catch the other story
there was a second movie that got killed
breaking news
girl another hobby gets cancelled there
is this yes i just don't remember what
it was
it was an animated scooby-doo film
so
this was a charming
so i the the um
the producer of that is a guy that i
know and and and we like follow each
other on social media and i saw him
share
like you know totally heartbroken was
completely blindsided by this news our
film was basically done
um and it was really good you know this
guy's been doing warner brothers
animation scooby-doo and flintstones and
things like that for decades he's he's
he's like
you know literally staff employee it's
like old school you know he works on the
ranch a lot and everything and and uh so
um
for those who don't know there's two
warner brothers campuses there's the
water tower campus and then there's also
the ranch
which is where they did like
friends and or at least that's where the
fountain was at friends and
it's also the big courtyard from the end
of the omega man but uh
uh the yeah and the ranch is where a lot
of the animation yeah i did a i did a um
flintstones direct to dvd movie for
warner brothers like 12 years ago and
visited their offices on the ranch and
it was so cool yeah because yeah they've
got they've got all these like under
glass in the lobby like the original
[ __ ] bugs hand drawn and it's [ __ ]
awesome but
and anyway this guy uh tony cervoni's
his name the tony cervoni yeah the the
producer
they were
they were so close to the end that he go
they had hired a friend of mine named
dara taylor to score this scooby-doo
movie and he goes um
what do you do when you're so close to
the finish line and you've already
booked the orchestra and then warner
brothers cancels your movie you [ __ ]
record it anyway and so five days after
scooby had been canceled they were at
warner brothers of the big orchestra and
just said [ __ ] it and recorded the
entire school can he do anything with
the music
no but can he pick can you stick them
brother still owns all the music and
like that will all be locked in with
them
but but the composer dara she'll be able
to basically parade around this [ __ ]
awesome like that's like johnny cash
level
it became a story like i saw the tweet
about it from like deadline or whatever
went viral
of like people going wow that's such a
because that was kind of got lost in the
the the yeah the two big movie
cancellations but the back girl was just
so much bigger that people didn't
realize this other one got canceled and
a really cool kind of silver lining
emerge so if nothing else dara has a has
a great
you know demo reel piece too that's all
you can use it for that's super
interesting i feel like the
um ezra
finally had a statement
as well regarding the flash because
everyone was like if you're canceling
fat girl what's happening with the flash
because of all this controversy
regarding like i think they've been
looking looking for a reason to get rid
of ezra miller well but i think they
just issued an apology as in ezra miller
just issued a sort of apology which i
don't think would happen without pr
intervention which makes me think flash
is happening
lawyers i imagine this oh
don't think they wrote that at all kgb
i mean i would think maybe even wb wrote
it it was i don't even know that ezra
miller would agree with it based on the
stuff that's been happening um i feel
like that's the thing that they were
like we have to get this out so that
ezra miller can still be in the flash
and we could do this i think that's
still going to release the movie right
well
seeing that today uh probably a far
higher budget i would think
yeah
i mean there's a long term investment
yeah in that it's like proper yeah sorry
let me find the quote for anyone who
missed it um
statement is
having recently gone through a time of
intense crisis i now understand that i
am suffering complex mental health
issues and have begun ongoing treatment
i want to apologize to everyone that i
have alarmed and upset with my past
behavior i am committed to doing the
necessary work to get back to a healthy
safe and productive stage in my life
if that's true that's incredible yeah
that's great and i wish them all the
best yep 100 you know it's also true
uh kids were banned from going to the
cinema in suits i told you uh
and just wanted to get that in there
before we do you
what else everybody missed because of
the big
conversation about ezra miller the
conversation about
mike bithell's drinking coca-cola
mike bethel looks good today
thank you you look good today
um
uh yeah carrick kerry cut my hair a
couple weeks ago oh you haven't seen me
since yes yes so yeah i've had one since
surely we've asked this before but is
she like extra good at cutting hair
because of what she does for a living
so this is it's a transferable skill so
yes my my partner makes some puppets for
stop-motion films so she's used to like
working on heads like that big so this
is easy mode she doesn't periodically
just look and go you know what i want
something different shaves your head
grafting
on like trying to just make a new yeah
basically takes out my spine and
rebuilds a different kind of hair
cutting skill
have you ever shaved
short fans if you've ever shaved your
head oh yeah my entire teenage year
i had a
skin head but a skin head yeah yeah i
think everybody should do it once you
need to know what your what your scalp
looks like it's important information to
have going based on running my fingers
through my hair my skull will be very
[ __ ] weird looking cool and i don't
think i don't think i need to expose
myself or the world to that weird
misshapen
like you know it's like if you freeze
frame halfway through the end of indiana
jones when the the guy's face is melting
and yeah i'm pretty sure that if you
[ __ ]
exactly
that's last crusade for everybody was
wondering thank you appreciate that
appreciate the truth um
i'm talking about the end of raiders but
yes
i like oh i think you're talking about
the innovation or the last crusade
actually you're yeah donovan i think
that i think yours is a better pull
actually yours is more apt that's a
skull as opposed to melting yep
so back to backhoe experts say
dave experts say this is such a vague
thing to say because like
i've been using as an expert before
sometimes i've done like interviews for
bbc or sky news where they're like how
do you feel about this and i'm like well
you're asking me the question so i have
to answer it as best i can but i don't
[ __ ] know it and this could be the
exact same thing for this
um experts say wb was not confident in
the film and decided to cut its losses
rather than release a film that does not
fare well
which as a result would hurt the wb
brand or the batman franchise going
forward they may have decided that the
benefit of any income earned by
releasing the film would be outweighed
by the negative image produced by the
film bombing at the box office coupled
with the tax savings of netting the loss
from batgirl against wb's other income
garbage and they were like oh no we must
listen to them i really hope not no i i
i think it's more likely that those
people don't earn them nearly enough
money i think for two years for them to
pay attention they're running good right
now they have the batman did incredibly
well
the joker joker 2 already has high did
incredibly well so i think they're
trying to reshape it from being a little
less maybe cwe
and a little bit more
into that it did have a little bit of
that cw i thought it was a cw movie i
didn't realize it was going to be like
this was what michael keaton was coming
back for
so that what i can't believe wishing on
the cw after celebrating raul's career
up to this point
he makes fun of it more than anyone else
i i don't i don't i don't fault them for
i'm but i'm speaking specifically to the
dc-ness of it
uh it's it's not bad but it's it's if
you look and go oh we should be aiming
more towards this because the batman and
joker have
eyepiece notwithstanding
that caliber of filmmaking and that
caliber of
consciousness then that kind of that's
going to be interesting how they thread
that needle because they've also
announced they want to do like the whole
cinematic universe thing again right
yeah well they're talking about doing
something penguin or aren't they they're
like they're they're talking about so
are they going to try and are we going
to see like
the joker and the batman kind of that's
one thing that i love about what dc has
done that i would way i prefer to what
marvel is currently doing but well i'm
gonna say the numbers kind of agree with
me is that you have massively different
movies with completely different tones
that still use these characters that you
know and love and universe that you know
and love but they don't all have to be
together so i don't have to go to the
movie and be like wait what am i
forgetting from this last one or the
thing that i watched 10 years ago it's
just like they're all really really like
the the variety of every single movie in
the batman catalog how vastly different
they are for the past 20 30 years
it's i way prefer it i'm like yeah give
me whatever the [ __ ] you want make it
weird and different every time
yeah i i think the ips can stand up i
don't think they have to be speaking to
each other i think we've tried that and
now we can go back to doing something a
little more standalone that's just me
yeah
yeah i mean even the joker and the
batman are more similar in tone but
they're still not technical that's what
i'm saying is i'm interested in whether
they can because they've said that's
what they're doing now they're doing
they've got a 10-year plan apparently
they're going to do the cinematic
universe thing it's like that seems that
seems to miss the lessons of what's
working recently go for it
i gotta go to work
the dog just touched my alexa with his
nose and he made it read a joke
the dog just spent the electorate
it's why did the horse cross the road i
don't know it left before i could ask
the equestrian
what
right
not great i like it it's actually
terrible it's i'm wondering if the eyes
are not gonna
evolve i'd get rid of the dog
that's just that's just lowered the
quality all right we got to put him down
that's it yeah exactly back together
your discovery is just murder get ready
strikes again now they canceled the dog
uh um the last note on this article
before uh we let you go
there's currently a trend of
the video streaming services and
entering what they are calling a
rationalization phase so previously it
seemed like they were just about like
let's make this thing and let's get yeah
exactly of streaming services like let's
get this thing let's put a bunch of [ __ ]
on it oh make it happen
whereas now uh there's pressure on
subscriber growth versus declining
advertising markets so because there are
more streaming services they're
competing with each other more
subscriber growth is lesser across the
board because previously people might
have subscribed to all of them and are
now being more choosy so they have to be
a lot more careful with content than
they were previously and i feel like
that makes sense with the cancellation
of batgirl is like we're being very
selective now about what we're putting
on going forward and
what we want people to think the image
of the warner bros or hbo max app is
something for game developers to
remember as we enter into a subscription
era that there will probably be a big
boom
and then there will also be a chilling
after
yeah
that's the lesson i think for all of us
yep well so what do you take from that
like you're probably right but what is
the lesson
the lesson is
well yeah i mean basically the the if
you look at the history of uh streaming
platforms they have all done massive
expansion spend a lot of money and then
stopped
and uh and with games there is a
potential and i know a lot of developers
are kind of thinking about this that we
will have that similar period
make hayward sun shines but we also need
a plan for after save the money from the
boom
save the money from the boom
everybody save the money from the book
we hey
all we do here on this show is give out
great advice to
buy it buy game developers
high
i want someone to make that a shirt save
the money from the boom yes save money
from the zoom all right
don't do it
uh all right thank you for watching
everybody i'm a lot of facebook video
game writer that's mike pimple he's a
video game director that's trey becky's
a video game actor and that is austin
wintry he's a video game composer we
will see you next week
bye